you know i've never paid much attention
to high-profile murder cases around 40
people are murdered in this country
every single day all of these are sad
situations some sadder than others
perhaps but the media wants us to be
especially concerned
about certain cases and not others i
don't feel obligated to follow their
lead on that point or on any other point
frankly
that's why i haven't followed the gabby
potato case very closely horrible though
it is and for those who have been
similarly out of the loop just a quick
summary petito and her fiance brian
laundry set out on a cross-country road
trip back in early july they
documented their adventures on instagram
and youtube
petito made her last instagram post on
august 25th a week later laundry
returned home alone with no explanation
as to gabby's whereabouts several days
after that he went missing as well he
was possibly captured on a deer camera
footage earlier this week trekking
through the woods of northwest florida
meanwhile the body recovered in a
wyoming national park a few days ago has
now been officially identified as gabby
petito her death has been ruled a
homicide unsurprisingly
why has this case made national
headlines while other missing persons
and murder victims are relegated to the
local news if they get any coverage at
all it's not very hard to just discern
an answer to that
gabby petito already had a base of
followers on social media who were
interested in her life it makes sense
that they would be likewise interested
in the circumstances of her death she
was young attractive photogenic
the disappearance out in the wilderness
the fiance on the run the additional
details emerging like puzzle pieces
all of these factors make for a more
sensational story
they don't make her death more terrible
than anybody else's death they didn't
make her life more valuable or it's
taking more tragic but they do add up to
a compelling narrative
and it may sound crude to refer to a
real-life murder case in that way as a
compelling narrative and it is
but this is how it works in a society
where people consume
murder cases as entertainment
i mean true crime quote unquote is one
of the most popular genres on every
streaming service for a reason
even if in most cases it's only
partially true what you get in those
documentaries
if true at all
and this is part of the reason why the
national media selects and amplifies
certain murders and not others
though recently prominent members of the
national media itself have pointed to a
different explanation joy reid of msnbc
echoed the claims made by many on the
left
when she pegged the gabby potato
coverage as another instance of quote
unquote missing white woman syndrome
reed having never encountered a story
that she won't racialize argues that the
media and the public only care about
white people white women specifically
who go missing or turn up dead
she charges the media with quote
ignoring cases involving missing people
of color let's listen to her
but the way this story has captivated
the nation has many wondering why not
the same media attention when people of
color go missing well the answer
actually has a name missing white woman
syndrome the term coined by the late and
great gwen eiffel to describe the media
and public fascination with missing
white women like lacey peterson or
natalie holloway while ignoring cases
involving missing people of color we
have been sounding the alarm for nearly
14 years because of this when it comes
to missing persons of color men women
and children our cases are not taken
seriously and no one is looking for us
if we were to go missing
now if we're going this route
i could just as easily chalk it up to
sexism
when's the last time that a missing or
dead white man made the national
headlines
and if anti-black racism lies at the
heart of this
then why do white female alleged
murderers tend to captivate the public
even more than the murder of victims
casey anthony jodi arias amanda knox
i can't name a single black female
murderer off the top of my head
is it anti-black racism that leads us to
heap extra scrutiny on white murder
suspects
and yet still the basic observation made
by joy reid and others
cannot be denied black people are killed
or go missing every day
at a rate much higher than whites
actually
and none of them unless they're killed
by a cop
we'll go back to that in a second become
household names
here's a concrete example to illuminate
the point
two years ago i talked about this on my
show i've talked about it several times
so you might know about if you listen to
this show but you won't know about this
case if you if you trust the mainstream
media for your news coverage
two years ago a black woman named
brittany hill was shot and killed by
chicago gang members in broad daylight
while holding her one-year-old daughter
in her arms
um the footage captured by security
cameras is
haunting
on the surface the crime seems to
contain all of the elements that would
it would attract widespread media
coverage
you have a young woman shot dead in the
street the crime is caught on camera
she dies while laying on top of her
child to shield her from the bullets
it's a devastating story and a dramatic
story
there are many such stories in chicago
and other cities around the country but
this one is on film
and even in a place like chicago it's
not every day that a young woman is
executed in the middle of the afternoon
while holding a baby in her arms
so so why didn't the national media show
any interest in that event
why didn't joy read ever mention britney
hill's name
the very media that condemns us for
allegedly ignoring black deaths
is itself guilty of ignoring those same
deaths indeed it's entirely their fault
that the deaths are ignored
they're the ones who are supposed to be
calling attention to to to news stories
that's their whole job and they're not
doing it
joy reid has her own show on msnbc a
national platform
she could have single-handedly made
britney hill a household name
and yet she ignored her death entirely
how can that be explained
and don't tell me she didn't hear about
it i mean i heard about it
i'm not in the mainstream media and i
heard about it
and i talked about it
why didn't she
so how do you explain this
i think it's easily explained
the national media disregarded brittany
hill because hill was murdered by black
men
the vast majority of black female and
black male murder victims are killed by
black men
that's why joy reid and her ilk ignore
them even as they accuse everyone else
of ignoring them
they don't want to discuss those deaths
because they don't want to talk about
the perpetrators who caused the deaths
as it turns out there are two major
factors deciding whether a murder case
will appear in national headlines the
identity of the victim matters
but so does the identity of the alleged
killer
to pass the media litmus test the case
must be sensational or easily
sensationalized
and it must also be politically useful
a white woman murdered by a white man
fits that bill
that fits both qualifications
potentially
so does a black man or woman killed by
police that's why those names become
household names
well yeah we we don't have there there
are no household names that come to mind
of a black man or woman
killed by another black civilian
uh but we can all name
several black people have been killed by
cops
can you name any white people who have
been killed by cops off the top of your
head again if you listen to the show
maybe you can but if you rely on
mainstream media you wouldn't be able to
and what explains that again because
it's politically convenient it's all
about the perpetrator
but a black person killed by a black
person who's a civilian certainly fails
to meet this criteria and so does a
white man killed by anyone of any
identity group
i mean what
there are circumstances where a dead
white woman can become a household name
there are circumstances where a
uh a dead black person becomes a
household name there's almost almost no
circumstance where a dead white guy
becomes a household name it doesn't
matter how he dies
we're not hearing about it
now rare exceptions can be made to that
final rule every once in a while a dead
white man might provide political fodder
to the left even if they have to lie
about the circumstances surrounding his
death see brian sicknick for an example
and of course none of this applies to
the dead white men who make the
headlines because the media wants to
mock their deaths like the various white
conservative radio hosts who have
succumbed to covet
but the common thread tying all of this
together
and making sense of all of it
is the media's steadfast refusal to
bring attention to anything that may
conflict or at least fails to advance
their ideological agenda
if it bleeds it leads right that used to
be the motto
we could only long for those cynical yet
still simpler times now nowadays
it might be it you know if if it bleeds
it might lead
or it might be locked in a vault and
buried under the earth it all depends on
who is doing the bleeding
and who's responsible for spilling the
blood
and how it all gels with the political
narrative
so joy reid is right to call out the
media for how it handles these cases
her mistake was in exempting herself
from that criticism
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated